SETH LADD: Well I think
we're going to go
ahead and get started.
Welcome everybody.
This is Dartisans,
Episode Four.
This week we have very special
guests, the Dart Editor team
and Phil Quitslund.
Hi Phil how's it going?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great.
Hey, Seth.
Hey, everyone.
SETH LADD: Thanks for
joining us today.
I've been seeing a lot of
releases is from the Dart
Editor team, and you
guys are cranking.
I'm sure everyone's going to be
excited to see what you've
got working in the latest
builds, see the demo we're
going to go into shortly, and
then hear a little bit about
where you're going
with the Editor.
So I really appreciate it.
And I think we should
get started with
a really cool demo.
I know you've got some stuff to
show off so are you ready
to show us what's latest and
greatest in the Editor there?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Sure,
yeah, absolutely.
SETH LADD: Share your
screen away.
PHIL QUITSLUND: All right.
SETH LADD: All right,
we're good.
PHIL QUITSLUND: We're good?
OK, great.
So one of the first things
that you'll notice after
launching the Editor is a
Welcome page, and the Welcome
page features a host
of samples.
And those samples are there to
help you get started with Dart
and get started with
the Editor.
So that's just as good a jumping
off point as any.
So let's dive into it.
My favorite sample is Clock,
so let's jump into that.
So when you click the Clock
sample on the Welcome page, it
will bring the Clock application
into the Editor,
ready for you to play with.
And you'll notice quickly on
the left hand side, in the
files view, we have a new folder
and in it, we have a
bunch of resources.
One thing that's worth
mentioning, this is sort of a
new feature for folks
that have been
using Editor for awhile.
We just recently added
some new emphasis.
You'll notice that Clock.dart
is emphasized in bold here.
And the reason for that is that
Clock.dart is essentially
the entry point of
this application.
It's a library and it turns
out that in nontrivial
applications, just this little
bit of emphasis is really
useful to help folks navigate.
So we've opened up the source
but we want to see what this
thing does.
So luckily with the Dart Editor,
it's very easy to get
up and running.
So to run this application, we
just go over to the Run Tool
item in the toolbar, or
alternatively we go to the
Tools menu and select Run.
And then as quickly as that,
we have a running Dart
application.
And what's worth pointing out
about this is that this is
running, you'll see over here,
we're launching Clock in a
special build of Chromium, the
Chromium browser, that
includes the Dart VM.
So this is actually running in
the Dart VM in Chromium.
So that's all fine and well.
To give you some kind of sense
for what it's like to actually
work with Dart, let's introduce
sort of a simple edit.
Now I happen to know a little
bit about this code.
So I know where I'm going.
What I'd like to do is I'd like
to change the speed of
these bouncing balls.
So to do that, I'm going
to navigate to a
class called Balls.
And one quick and easy
way to do that is
through the search box.
So if you go to the search box
and start typing, it will
refine your results to match
what you've typed.
So I'm going to navigate
to the Balls type.
And now, once I've opened this
in the Editor, the next thing
I want to do is I want
to navigate to
a particular member.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to open the Quick
Outline view, which is a
kind of handy overlay.
On the Mac, it's Option-Open,
or with this
Context menu, click.
There's the method
I'm looking for.
It's called tick.
And what I want to do is I want
to change the way that
this delta is getting
calculated.
So let's change it
a little bit.
Now I'm going to click Save,
go back to my browser, and
it's a simple matter of
reloading the browser to see
the effect of my change.
Oh, very slow.
I think actually, I'm feeling a
little more hyper than that.
So let's change it and reload.
So that's the edit/refresh cycle
with the Dart Editor,
and running in Chromium.
And what we're hoping is that
people will be delighted with
how quick it is to
test out changes.
Now that we have a file open in
the Editor, I want to draw
your attention to some of the
things that we've done in the
Editor to help make you an
effective Dart programmer.
So first of all, unsurprisingly,
the Editor
will give you some feedback when
you've gone completely
off the rails.
So for instance, if we introduce
a syntax error here
and save it, we'll notice
at the bottom we
get a bunch of errors.
So that's useful.
More subtly and more
interestingly, it will give us
some feedback when we've done
unhappy things with types.
So this is one of the places
where Dart really shines and
the Editor can really
piggy back on that
feature of the language.
So lastTime, we happen
to know, is an int.
And if we assign a string to
an int, you would expect a
warning, and indeed
we get one.
Now once we have types, we can
do other interesting things to
help you be a productive
programmer.
So since we know lastTime is
an int, you would hope that
the tool would be able to
do something with that.
And sure enough, it can.
And it can calculate some
pretty constructive code
completion proposals.
So since lastTime is an int,
we can complete all valid
methods on ints.
So that is really,
really useful.
And I think folks that are
coming from other, well, from
typed languages like Java, for
instance, are going to take
that for granted.
But this is very useful
in the context of--
Well, coming over from
JavaScript, this is
refreshing.
So I think that's what I want to
point out about the sample.
Next you're probably wondering
what it's like to
build your own apps.
And to do that, first
let's close this.
And to create an application
with the Dart Editor, you
simply go to the File menu,
select New Application.
It will come up with a wizard,
and this wizard will generate
some sample content for us.
So let's make a web app.
And here we have a very
simple web app.
(If could only type.
The Editor does not make you a
better typist, unfortunately.)
So once again we can just
run it like this.
It runs, and, very good.
So I mentioned a couple things
that you can do to navigate
and I want to point out one
more while we're here.
t you hold down the command key,
this will give us a very
handy affordance for opening
the declarations of types
inside the Editor panes.
When I hold down the
Command key and
hover, I can hop around.
But more excitingly, I can drill
into externally-defined
types and interfaces.
So this is something that comes
in the bundled libraries.
The String interface, and
we can hop right to it.
Similarly we can hop
around inside here.
Now it's worth noting, you'll
notice what's happened on the
left-hand side in
the Files views.
We've expanded this synthetic
node which points off to the
bundled SDK libraries.
So obviously you can
navigate this--
It's useful, maybe, to navigate
this to get some kind
of a sense for how the SDK
libraries are structured.
Another way to zoom around and
take a look at SDK libraries,
of course, is through
the search box.
So if you happen to know, you're
guessing likely, that
there's some HTML-related
classes--
And here, we can zoom
into one of them.
So before we open for questions,
I want to point out
a few more launching options.
Up until this point, we've just
been running things in
the Dartium--
in the context of the Dartium
browser, so running on the VM.
But you may be interested to
note that we can also run
things just as well as
JavaScript apps.
So we'll create a new Launch.
So the way that we
did that, sorry.
You can go to Tools,
Manage Launches.
This will open this wizard
and create a new Launch.
This time we're going to choose
a Dart Web Launch.
We'll call it "webby." We need
to select the "webby" HTML
file as an entry point.
We're going to use the system
browser, apply it, and run it.
What's happening here, you'll
see in the Console.
Now we're generating JavaScript
and we're opening
that file, in this
case, in Safari.
Because that's what I've chosen
as my default browser.
Also worth noting, when we
look at these Launches.
You may have noticed--
Folks who have been playing with
the Editor, this is a bit
of a teaser.
There are a few other options
when you launch.
And one thing that I want to
just point out very quickly.
Many folks on [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
have discovered that there's
some early debugging support.
And while we aren't turning it
on by default, I think it's
already fully baked enough
to be pretty useful.
So let me just quickly demo
what that looks like.
So going back to our original
"webby" Launch configuration,
we enable debugging.
And just apply it, and run it.
And now let's set
a break point.
So setting a break point is
a simple matter of double
clicking in the gutter here.
Now we have a break
point set here.
I suppose we want
to run it again.
When we run it, you'll notice
that this debugger
panel has opened up.
We're stopped where we expect to
be, and you'll notice that
values are propagated
to the view.
And you can actually get them
also by hovering over.
And as you would expect
in a debugger, you
can just click resume.
Finally I should point out there
was one other option
that you may have noticed.
So earlier I pointed out that
we get these warnings.
And this is not strictly
an error in Dart.
But you can run the VM, or you
can connect to the VM in
checked mode.
And when you do that, it gets
a little bit more strict.
And in that case, what we should
see here in our Console
is a stack trace.
Because in this case, we're
saying that assignment is--
We're going to treat that
as an error at runtime.
That's about it that I had
set for the canned demo.
Do we want to switch over
to some questions?
SETH LADD: Yeah, thanks Phil.
Go ahead and pop off your
screen sharing there.
Awesome.
So for everyone who's just
joined us, this is Dartisans
Episode Four.
We have special guests, the
Dart Editor team from
Portland, who's just
finished up a demo.
And this is all being recorded,
so if you missed the
demo you'll be able to
see it on YouTube.
It's very, very slick.
We saw debugging, we saw
warnings, we saw launching
into Dartium A lot
of good stuff.
So thank you, Phil.
So why don't we take just a
second to introduce yourself.
I know you guys are in Portland,
but who's there with
you in the room, and what have
you guys been doing, and what
led you to Dart Editor?
PHIL QUITSLUND: So I'll start.
So I'm Phil Quitslund.
I work on the Dart Editor
team in sunny Portland.
And before, I had been working
in the Eclipse plug-in space
for a long time, doing tooling
primarily for Java and Java
extensions.
I was in academia for a while
doing programming language
research and language tools.
And have happily found my way
onto the Dart team and am
doing similar kinds of things
with the Dart Editor.
And my focus on the Editor has
been, search has been a big
part of my focus.
SETH LADD: We saw a demo
that was very cool.
Who's behind you, back there?
DEVON CAREW: Hi.
I'm Devon Carew.
And I worked with Phil at
Instantiations before Google.
And previous to that, I worked
at a couple of companies in
Boston on work writing Java
virtual machines.
And mostly on the Editor, I've
been working on debugging and
launch support, which you
saw a little bit of.
So if you find any bugs
in debugging, you can
send them to me.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH LADD: Thanks, Devon.
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
KIRSTIE: Hi.
I'm Kirstie.
And I'm also part of the team
that came over from
Instantiations--
PHIL QUITSLUND: Me too.
KIRSTIE: I've been working with
these folks for a while
now, mainly doing
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] loops and
Java productivity tools, and
now working on the Dart
Editor, So I've been
working with--
Devon and I have been working on
the debugging and launching
story for a while now.
SETH LADD: Well thanks,
everyone, for taking the time.
I keep hearing this word
Eclipse over and over.
Can you tell us just a little
bit about Instantiations?
Because I think that's an
interesting story about how we
actually got here.
And then the question that we
always get is, so is this
thing Eclipse?
So can you help demystify
what we just saw?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Let's
start with the last
part that you asked.
As Kirstie said, at
Instantiations, our bread and
butter was building
productivity
tools built on Eclipse.
And so our primary customers
there were folks that were
using the Eclipse platform
in all of its grandness.
Now what we're trying to do with
the Dart Editor is parlay
some of our experience in the
larger Eclipse community.
There are some pain points,
especially for novice users.
So for end users who picked
up Eclipse, they found it
sometimes threatening and a
little bit overly large.
So we've been striving to do
with the Dart Editor is build
something with a smaller
UX footprint.
And just streamlined a little
bit, and emphasizing a kinder,
gentler more streamlined
user experience.
Which is not to denigrate
Eclipse at all.
I think where we're trying to
really kind of focus this
effort on clean and simple
and small and not open.
So Eclipse is this great
open architecture.
The Dart Editor is much
more curated.
SETH LADD: I think the key there
is the word, editor.
We don't really call it an
IDE, because I think that
implies a different kind
of experience.
And we're very focused
on an editor.
What would an editor focused
on Dart look like, and feel
like, and act like?
And that's what you
guys are building.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Right.
SETH LADD: The other question we
always get, so is this ever
going to turn into a plug-in?
What's the story behind
a plug-in?
How did we not write
How did we end up at a
standalone editor?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Anybody else
want to answer that one?
I can answer it, but--
DEVON CAREW: I think initially
we were very concerned with
the UX, user experience of our
tooling and that definitely
led us to the road of this
curated, smaller
version of an editor.
Especially new users have
a good on-ramp, a good
experience.
And I would say largely, we
haven't done a plug-in version
because of bandwidth reasons.
If we try to concentrate on too
much, you're not able to
perform well on what
you're trying to
do- what's most important.
And we have had requests for
plug-in versions, a plug-in
version of the Editor,
Dart plug-ins.
And we may introduce
them at some point.
But I think that's mostly to do
with what other things we
would be prioritizing about
that, where we would be
putting our effort.
PHIL QUITSLUND: I think
that's right.
I should just add one--
You've made me realize one thing
that I meant to demo is
that in the application we have
the feedback mechanism.
And we hope that people take
advantage of that to give us
feedback just like this.
There also obviously
is the public bug
tracker at Dart Bugs.
And like Devon said, there is
an open ticket that has had
some kind of interesting
activity on it.
So if folks want to explore
that issue any further,
they're welcome to
chime in there.
DEVON CAREW: And to add to
what Phil said, we have
changed the behavior of the
Editor based on user feedback.
We had a different type
of explorer, a
navigator for your code.
And based on a specific amount
of user feedback we changed it
to a different style, from
the Library view
to the Files view.
And if we saw enough feedback
on various issues we would
definitely take that into
account and probably change
what we were doing.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Right.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
We definitely appreciate that.
And you touched on it before.
There's a SEND FEEDBACK
mechanism in the Editor.
But the Editor, just like the
entire Dart project, is
open-source.
And so you can go to
dartbug.com, file your
experiences, ask for new
features, file bugs.
Or use the SEND FEEDBACK.
The team listens and triages
all these issues.
And so we definitely
appreciate that.
This is the Editor's technology
preview, just like
the rest of the project.
And things are being re-factored
every week based
on the feedback we get.
So we definitely appreciate
that.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Patches
welcome.
SETH LADD: Yes definitely.
Let's take a question from
the moderator here.
This question is, the
top question is
voted by our listeners.
What are their future plans for
supporting other languages?
Or at least syntax highlighting
in quote
completion for things like
HTML, CSS, or Go?
Where do you see the Editor
fitting in with at
least HTML and CSS?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Well,
that's interesting.
You can speak to that.
That's a very hotly
requested item.
DEVON CAREW: I would definitely
say HTML and CSS is
on our near-term.
I don't think Go is on the
strategy right now.
But yeah, we've had
requests for it.
And for simple stuff like syntax
highlighting, it makes
a big difference.
It makes it easier
to read the code.
And we actually have
some code for that
which is not completed.
So I think it will land
the next few weeks.
SETH LADD: Great.
Thank you.
Especially as Dart, first and
foremost, is a modern,
structured web programming
language, I think that's going
to get a lot of usage
out of that.
Here's another question
from the moderator.
And for everyone watching, feel
free to join the Hangout.
I believe I shared it to all
the extended circles there.
We love the live questions,
so don't be shy.
This next question,
MBC or MBP web
application scaffold generator.
That sounds like a feature
request. If Google's building
guit-like framework in Dart--
which we definitely
are looking at--
What does the UI stack, or UI
app stack, look like for Dart?
Then a GUI-based model creator
for App Engine SQL?
No SQL back end would be
really interesting.
So I think what this question
is really saying is, how far
do you see the Editor going?
Right now we saw a lot of cool
stuff about the syntax, and
launching, and debugging.
But at some point we'll
introduce an app stack.
And people compile their Dart
apps into JavaScript, and
deploy that up to App Engine.
Where's your head at, and how
far do you think that Editor's
going to go?
PHIL QUITSLUND: I think what
Devon said earlier about a
plug-in version of the Editor
is exactly right.
I mean, I think it's entirely
a matter of bandwidth.
I can't imagine that
we wouldn't--
I don't know.
I think as the more opinionated
that the Dart team
gets about a UI app stack, and
the sooner we have a real
story for that, the sooner
we can start building our
tooling around it.
But again I think that I think
that's just a matter of
interest and bandwidth.
But I can't imagine we wouldn't
want to do that.
It sounds very exciting.
But again I also encourage this
should be translated into
a feature request. And put
on the public tracker.
SETH LADD: I'd like to turn it
back to some of the stuff that
we saw you doing
in the Editor.
You showed that if type
annotations exist in the code,
that the Editor can
give you warnings.
We also saw an error for
something you checked for
checked mode.
Can you just take a minute and
explain the differences
between what the Editor and
just really what the Dart
system considers warnings and
errors and checked mode?
And can you demystify all
this a little bit?
Because I know that if you add
these static type annotations
to your code, the
Editor really--
Like, a lot of these cool
features turn on.
Talk to us a little bit about,
what are warnings?
What are errors?
And how do they manifest
themselves?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Anybody else
want to take that one?
DEVON CAREW: I'll jump in
here for a little bit.
PHIL QUITSLUND: And I'll
take up after that.
DEVON CAREW: But I am not
a Dart language expert,
by any means so--
Yeah.
Generally, the type
annotations--
In some places on
your Dart code--
Basically, we don't
want the types to
affect the runtime behavior.
They're there more as helpful
hints to the user.
So if you see a warning,
it means that
this is probably incorrect.
But the VM and the browser are
going to execute it just fine.
Whereas an error is more
like your code is--
We're not compiling, but
it wouldn't compile
traditionally.
And it will not run correctly.
So that's when you see the
difference between a warning
and an error.
ERIC CLAYBURG: So
are you guys--?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Yeah, sure.
DEVON CAREW: Sure.
ERIC CLAYBURG: Oh yeah.
I was going to say so it's
really not even that
straightforward.
Sometimes even when the Editor
is showing an error, the VM
will actually execute code
somewhere up until that point.
So the definition of a compile
time error in Dart just means
that you won't be able to
execute the code, and you
won't be able to catch an
exception, and keep going.
So that's the real difference
between a
warning and an error.
Warnings, you can turn
on checked mode.
But if you put a try/catch block
around them, it throws a
special kind of type exception
that could be caught.
I don't recommend coding
like that.
But this is something
that we do in our
unit tests, for example.
So the real point of the
warnings is to give people who
want the extra safety of types
a way to do type safety,
without letting types get in
the way of people who don't
use a type system or
casually using it.
So for example, you showed
assigning an int to a string
and everything working fine.
If you want to write code that
uses duck typing, where you
have an object to implement some
fields, and you assign it
to another object that has some
of those same fields, and
you access only those fields,
everything works fine.
It's just the warnings that
would get in the way.
I hope that clarified, and
not confused people.
PHIL QUITSLUND: No,
that's great.
SETH LADD: And Eric,
can you introduce
yourself real briefly?
ERIC CLAYBURG: Oh yeah, sorry.
I'm Eric.
I work on the Dart Editor team
now, and I've been working on
the static analyzer.
And as a part of the
old Dart seed team.
And previous to that, at Google,
I worked on the Google
Web Toolkit and Maps bindings
for Google Web Toolkit.
SETH LADD: Thanks Eric.
And I should probably point
out the static analyzer is
what's looking through all the
code as you type it and as you
save it, and generates those
yellow squigglies.
So that's what's looking through
it and using the
language spec, and giving you
those warnings early on.
I think that's really where you
start to see the power of
type annotations pay off,
is in the Editor.
Editor's where the
users actually
interact with the system.
So you add those types, and you
get these early warnings.
You catch those bugs early.
That, to me, is where
the power really
starts to kick in.
So I appreciate that.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Yeah and also,
the type annotations also make
it much, much easier for us
to propose intelligent
completions.
I think on the--
I can't make any promises about
a time frame, but I know
folks are very interested in
adding some basic type
inferencing.
So I think, depending on how far
we want to go with that,
hopefully in the not-so-long
term, you'll start to see some
custom code completion in places
where there isn't an
explicit type.
On the other hand, it kind
of gives you some nice
encouragement to use type.
So I think it'll be interesting
to see what kind
of culture grows around the
types and how many people
really leverage the
optional types.
But that still remains
to be seen.
SETH LADD: Thanks, Phil.
That was exactly the next
question from Adam in San
Francisco, was, when do you
think, or can the Dart Editor
handle at least local
type inference?
And so it's good to see that
that's on the radar.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Yeah, we were
just talking about that.
Kind of an idiom that seems
to be kind of growing--
Well, something that people are
kind of trying on here, is
the notion of types at
all the boundaries.
So having all your interfaces
well-typed.
So more specifically, if you
have a method declaration, you
wouldn't have any vars
in the signature.
Those would all be typed.
But in the body of your
method, you may
not use types, right?
That affords you some
flexibility.
But that being said, if you want
to do type inference in
that context, that's much
easier than global type
inference, where you have to
do an analysis that reaches
further out of that scope.
So I think that--
Bryan isn't here.
Bryan's the one who's been
thinking most deeply about
what type inferencing for the
Editor would look like.
But I think folks are very
keen to have that happen,
because I think that would be
hugely valuable to users, and
Adam, at least.
SETH LADD: Yes.
Well, with so many people from
the Dart team here joining us,
which is a really rare
treat, I'm kind of
curious to turn it around.
What are some of the things that
you as the Editor team
would like to know more about
from our Dart users out there.
There's a whole bunch of people
using the Editor, and
the language, and libraries.
This is a good chance for you
guys to ask your own questions
that people can either respond
here in the moderator, or the
hang out, or just when they file
bugs, or join the mailing
list. What is it that you
guys want to know?
Anything curious?
PHIL QUITSLUND: Hmm.
Dan, you want to chime in?
DAN RUBEL: I'd say definitely
feature requests, where you're
getting road blocked, how we
can help you understand the
language quickly, bugs
you're running into.
All those sort of typical
product-centric
product-realized questions
that can help drive us to
determine where we should
spend our time
in the short term.
SETH LADD: With that, I
want to say, hi Dan.
How are you?
DAN RUBEL: Howdy.
SETH LADD: Can you introduce
yourself real briefly?
DAN RUBEL: I'm the TL for the
Dart Editor project log.
I've been working on Eclipse
plug-ins for 10-plus years,
working with the guys in
Portland, doing that.
All prior to Google, and now
part of the Dart Editor team.
SETH LADD: I feel so lucky.
I really feel you're the right
guys building this project.
You guys have been doing these
kind of editors, and IDEs, and
frameworks for a long time.
So I think we're lucky to have
you guys working on it.
Dan, I'm going to put you
on the spot for just
real briefly here.
One of the things we're hearing
about, and we love to
hear, is that people are using
Dart for some fairly large,
nontrivial projects.
Some public, some private.
But they've been running
into slower analysis
times with the Editor.
I know you've been thinking
about ways
to make that better.
Can you talk just a little bit
about what you've seen, and
any kind of thoughts on
the future of the
analysis and speed?
DAN RUBEL: Speed is definitely,
performance is
definitely of interest
to us obviously.
We're addressing larger and
larger programs. it's the
basic things.
We need to speed up the
analysis itself and do
performance analysis there,
address the hot spots.
We are putting in place caching
so that things are not
analyzed multiple times.
Cache whatever we can.
In addition, Phil's added, and
Bryan has added some logic so
that you can exclude certain
areas and focus, so that even
if you open up a large directory
tree, you can focus
Editor on a particular area
and say, only analyze this
small portion of it.
So we're looking at things
both from an automated
standpoint and from a
user-driven standpoint to
improve performance.
SETH LADD: Great.
Thanks, Dan.
And we'll keep encouraging our
community to send us more
specific use cases
and scenarios.
Because I know we definitely
appreciate to see what those
projects look like.
That helps us get to the
root even quicker.
So we appreciate the community
feedback there.
ERIC CLAYBURG: This
is Eric again.
And we were talking to some
usability people, saying that
users are having trouble
interpreting some of the
warnings and errors.
And I was just putting out a
plea to get more specific
instances of those, to see if we
could help people by making
the messages better,
basically.
SETH LADD: Great,
thank you Eric.
That's awesome.
So please use our bug-tracking
system not just for bugs or
explicit feature requests.
You can also use the SEND
FEEDBACK button, and our
mailing list, and our
dartbug.com, just to send your
general thoughts and
experiences.
We love to hear that.
We can put the pieces together
and make it even better.
So thanks Eric, for offering
to do that.
Hi, Brandon.
Did you have a question for
the Dart Editor team?
BRANDON DONNELSON: I don't
have a question.
I thought I'd lurk.
I saw the request come across,
and I couldn't help myself.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Well, welcome.
Lurk away.
SETH LADD: Lurk away,
that's right.
BRANDON DONNELSON: You guys are
doing some awesome work.
DAN RUBEL: Well, thanks.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Thank you.
SETH LADD: We've got
just about five
or six minutes left.
And something that, it was kind
of a teasing hint I want
to end on, with one of the
latest announcements for the
Dart Editor team, was local
rename refactoring support.
I think that is going to
be really awesome.
Can you spend a few minutes
talking about, what's your
vision there, and what's coming
down maybe the next
couple releases with regards
to refactor?
DAN RUBEL: As our local analysis
improves, and again
type inferencing, in that area,
one of the first simple
things is rename.
Beyond that, I think all
of the typical Java,
Eclipse-related refactorings--
We would like to see
as many as we can.
We'll just take them
as we have time.
Extract Method, inline, Extract
Local, et cetera.
But again, we have to the bright
bread and butter things
first. Performance,
stability--
SETH LADD: OK.
Thanks, Dan.
I I'm personally very excited
for the refactoring support.
So looking forward
to that one.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Well I think
there's a lot of incentives to
do it right.
Because I think one of the
things that obviously is on
our mind as we're building this
tool is that we want to
emphasize all the
ways that Dart
distinguishes itself from--
well, the elephant in the
room is JavaScript.
There are lots of things that
are very challenging to do in
JavaScript.
And I think there are still--
Rename in Dart is not a piece of
cake either, because of the
typing story.
But I think that's something
that we're really keen to do
and to get right.
I think there are some
interesting new
UX challenges there.
So beyond just the analysis, I
think we need to come up with
potentially some innovative
ways to communicate to the
user when there are--
So a refactoring, a definition
of refactoring is something
that guarantees that behavior is
preserved before and after
the transformation.
And I think with the optional
type story, that gets
interesting.
And I think we still have some
exploring to do there.
But that's also where the
language geeks get really
psyched, because that's
it's a chance to do
something really new.
SETH LADD: OK.
Well, without any other
questions--
I don't see anything new showing
up in the moderator.
I'll take this opportunity to
again encourage everyone to
try out the Editor and
send the feedback.
And this team really
does listen.
They're really great at
responding quickly and they
push out releases so fast, it's
hard for me to catch up.
There's a SEND FEEDBACK button
in the upper right of the
Editor, there's dartbug.com
which links you straight to
our H2 tracking system.
That's a good place to put
explicit feature requests, and
any bugs you might
ever encounter.
And then, encourage you to
participate in the mailing
list. Our engineers participate
there, and listen
to what you have to
say, and a lot of
good discussion happens.
So please do.
This community is very, very
good and our engineers are
awesome at listening to what you
have. So please do give it
a shot and let us know.
We appreciate it.
And on behalf of the whole
Dart community, I want to
thank all you guys from the
Editor team, and everyone
watching at home for
joining us today.
This is really cool to see the
demo, to hear your thoughts,
and learn what's coming next.
So I really appreciate it.
So with that, I want to
say, thanks everyone.
This video will go
up on YouTube.
And thanks, everyone.
Have a great weekend.
DAN RUBEL: And thank you,
Seth, for coordinating.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Yeah, thanks.
SETH LADD: My pleasure.
BRANDON DONNELSON: Awesome.